[Music]
so this last week I was in Breckenridge
Colorado which is right outside of Vail
we were trying to ski and snowboard had
a great time and had two experiences
with businesses one was amazing it was a
restaurant called a tour which is right
outside of Vail it's in Vail will not
rest on amazing experience and I tweeted
it out I put it on Instagram but just
phenomenal experience I had with them
and then I had a terrible experience
with Avis and I did the same I put it on
Twitter
Avis contact I'll tell you a little bit
about what happened with Avis and I said
you know what Mario how about if we do
an episode on customer service and
customer experience the last one we did
I think on YouTube that thing's got over
300,000 views on a lot of you guys who
use it with bigger companies fortune 500
companies I am such a stickler about
customer service and customer experience
that when I go to a restaurant I pay so
close attention to it because I think it
matters for every business the reason
why Amazon is doing so well is because
this is an area they pay very close
attention to so with that being said
I'll give you eight common complaints
customers make you and I and nineteen
mistakes companies makes when it comes
down to customer service so before I get
into it I want to have a PDF at the end
you'll be able to pull this off and say
you know download and say this is a
mistake we'll make this is what we do
how can we improve this and do whatever
you want to do with your business so
stick around by the end of the video to
get that free pdf and if you got any
questions comments thoughts comment on
the bottom and if you haven't yet
subscribe to the channel click on the
subscribe button and the notifications
side right next to it so you can watch
the rest of the videos we have so let me
get right into it eight common
complaints you and I customers make
here's the first one I've been on hold
for 15 minutes have you ever said that
you've been on a line for 15 minutes no
one's answering you they're not even
giving you an option on call back I've
been on home for 15 minutes then they
answer the call the second one so this
is not the right department let me try
to get a hold of summary that can help
you okay great well it's also not my
department let me try to get a
supervisor because they can approve this
well who can really help me out why are
you transferring to four different
people which leads me to the next one
tell me if you've experienced this one
before so the person that transferred me
to you did they explain you my
frustration or the situation I mean no
so you mean to tell me I have to explain
it to again for eight minutes
yes oh that is so frustrating right
here's a fourth one you know I talked to
somebody in their monotone yes I
understand your situation sir let me see
what I can do for you I hope I make your
day better you don't care you're not
really trying to do customer service
it's just kind of like going down the
script here's a fifth one the product
doesn't do what you said it'll do
you said the products going to do you
over-promised and under-delivered number
six the competitor said they'll do it
better than you but you don't do this so
for instance the company will say well
we don't do it that way well we can't do
this and you say well Hertz does what
this place does the other day I'm at
Neiman Marcus I had a Giuseppe show I'm
like you know what I bought it from you
and this size is very tight I'd like to
be able to exchange it for a half size
bigger we have it perfect can I exchange
it no but Nordstrom does but Neiman
Marcus does Neiman Marcus doesn't so ask
how come you don't do it OSR policy but
Nordstrom does and the lady happened to
be used to work at Nordstrom's back in
the days number seven late responses on
electronic messages you try to get back
to somebody takes a week five days three
days two days very frustrating and last
but not least here's what's last but not
least companies that have zero customer
service I don't mean zero as in bad no
customer service there is no contact
there is no phone number you literally
have to go online and type in you know
such-and-such companies phone number and
you still cannot find one yet because
they choose not to do that now if you're
the business owner yourself watching
this you have to process these eight
different common complaints and say men
how do I address every one of these
things and train my employees my staff
my customer service myself so we don't
go through this by the way I've run a
business I've been on the customer side
end and I've been on the business owner
side and and I've been on the side that
I am the customer service so I'm the guy
running the business teaching my
customer service reps how to do it
better and I've been on the service of
trying to deal with customers and I was
ticked off half the time dealing with
them and I've been the customer so I'm
giving you the experience been in every
single aspect of it and I've been
frustrated at every single level which
leads me to the next one nineteen common
mistakes businesses make with customer
service let's get into the first one
here's the first one lack of training on
how to handle issues and here's what I
mean by like a training somebody comes
in
how are you and then they'll say well
you know here's the booklet and go study
the customer service part okay I read it
as if I read it it's like being on the
airline and they say is everybody here
willing and committing to you know
opening and following the guidelines in
case we have an emergency landing oh yes
I need a yes from everybody yes yes yes
and make sure you read the manual how
often have you grabbed their thing and
gone through it that's how some
companies treat customer service and
what I mean by training is role playing
if they say this you say this if they
say that you say this if they say this
you say this you're role playing all
those common eight objections and your
role playing role playing well if they
say I don't know what to say if they say
this that is all part of the training
mistake a company companies make number
two reactive instead of proactive so you
try to argue with the customer which by
the way you are never going to in it and
let me explain this part to you here was
the common thread would a this so I was
in Breckenridge the moment I dropped off
my car
I left my iPhone you know the earpods I
left the case the white case so I have
the actual earpods but the case you
charged I left in the middle right
console and I went I went to my flight I
called him the Denver International
Airport called him over and over and
over again they put me on signal on hold
for 60 minutes and 39 seconds secondly I
called their Lost and Found department
the mailbox was full I called it again
the mailbox was full I went through
every one of the five numbers to pick
that thing up no one answered the only
one that they answered the only one that
they answered was option number one
which was sales and they picked up and a
person that answer said I need to speak
to this a supervisor I was on hold for
15 minutes then I called Avis directly
when I called Avis directly and I spoke
to them I told my situation I got
transferred three times by the way every
single one of the people I dealt but I
have every single one of their names
except for one person every single one
of them made an excuse about why I'm the
one at fault and they said well sir our
policy is the same as everybody else I
said you don't understand your policy is
not the issue the issue is your mailbox
is full
I can't even leave a message for
somebody again but but that's that's
that's not and so excuse excuse 1601 I
will never listen to me I will never
ever use Avis ever again and I'm saying
this publicly to you I will never use
Avis again because to them everything
was justification until I finally got a
hold of somebody who was a supervisor
the lady's name was Dana so I'm not
gonna give the names the other people
died messed up but I will give the name
of a lady named Dana supervisor she gave
me her employee ID number I'm not gonna
put it out there
she said Patrick would you mind if I
called that number to see if the mailbox
is full or not I so please do so she
calls puts me on hold
comes back two minutes later she says
Patrick I called twice and you are right
the mailbox is full
and you are right this is our mistake
this is not acceptable the only person
that didn't argue that didn't make an
excuse that didn't justify the only
person was Dana and so you hear so many
companies that want to do that by the
way I've done it before as a customer
service guy working at Bally's before we
were just five but it's never effective
and we had to learn to adjust
so all I'm telling you right now
sometimes with the business if the
customer is making an issue it is an
issue that they dealt with you just need
to deal with and see what you can do to
improve that situation for them number
three lack of accessibility to customers
what do I mean by lack of accessibility
to customers you are not accessible I
can't get a hold of you I have a
complaint
sometimes that complaint if I talk to
you for 20 minutes I'm done I'm over it
but I can't get a hold you sort of
frustration is building up and building
up and building up and building up and
building up and then PO you get a
negative review and you could have
simply called me to be able to fix that
number for not willing to call an
audible that may go against your
protocol what do I mean by this
you'll hear businesses that I'll say
well sir we'd love to do and help you
out with that but that's just not our
protocol that's none of your protocol
how often have you experienced someone
like this I understand it but it's not
just our protocol and then you talk to a
supervisor it's not part of our protocol
look recently the Eagles beat the
Patriots in a Super Bowl where nobody
thought the Eagles were gonna win
everybody bet on the New England
Patriots you know the great one he won
the MVP 40 years oh it's just destiny
he's gonna want us you know six Super
Bowl and you know what happens the
Eagles have this play
it's a very weird play it's a play that
a coach came out with in college and
they have shown this play on Facebook
over and over again
it's got 2030 million views what a
quarterback goes behind the other Napa
Center the other offensive line and it
tricks everybody the ball comes to the
running back and then the other guy runs
back audible boom throws it to the
quarterback catches it Nick Foles
touchdown and that was the touchdown
that helped them win the New England
Patriots because sometimes you got to
call an audible
sometimes you got to call an audible
same thing with customer service
sometimes your protocol may need an
audible because this situation here you
need to go above and beyond to make this
customer happy and some companies are to
Richard no no it is out of our protocol
so I'm not willing to change that is a
mistake long term number five not coming
through on your customer service this
one's fairly simple if you say to a
customer you gonna do something you kind
of gotta come through for number six
lack of organization on customer
complaints what do I mean by this if
you're running a business you got to
have some kind of a CRM or someplace
where you make notes of the complaint
that the customer made so the complain
that this customer made is under the
existing complaint of this customer so
John Doe note section this person was
very frustrated with that thought that
that then email to the group and maybe
your supervisor or maybe you insane
this person complained about something
that I honestly they don't know how to
help what do we do about this and that
threat is being shared as well and
document it so you know maybe we need to
have a training opportunity for this to
teach the other customer service reps on
how to handle an issue like this next
let's go to number seven given the
customer to run around this is Avis they
give me the runaround I called so many
different people and I'm a principal guy
and I didn't like that I don't need the
money I don't know I told the guy said
listen I'm not expecting you to give me
my money back I'm expecting you to
answer your phone I don't need another
six hundred dollars in my pocket I need
service and I gave you shot and you
didn't come through and three different
people gave me the runaround until one
person named Dana didn't seventy-five
percent of my experience three out of
the four people gave me the runaround
you don't want to give the runner on to
your customers that you're dealing with
number eight
strictly automation this is the whole
sending the copy/paste script and
message
to people oh we understand your
frustration we hope we feel better I
hope we made your day better and tada
hopefully you'll have a better
opportunity next time we do this and
you're like wait a minute this sounds
like a very scripted message they just
gave me rather than actually telling me
and show me that you being real it's
like a robot talking to me no one likes
that nowadays number 9 now using the
basics let me explain to you the basics
when you're speaking to them thank you
please request I understand this is not
necessarily frustration
it's just etiquette people like to be so
thank you for doing business with us
listen John I want to share something
with you first of all you're frustrated
you're upset thank you in the first
place for giving us a second shot and
I'm disappointed with the fact that we
couldn't come through
having said that can you tell me a
little bit more about your experience so
maybe we can find a way to make this
thing better for you what is it and
they're going to go through it but talk
to them yet at the same time you think
you use request use please use I
understand here they're not on so you
can finally find a way to make it better
number 10 this regarding loyalty what do
I mean by loyalty look there are certain
customers you have that are true
believers let me explain some to you you
always got to take you to your true
believers if I've been a customer of
your gym for 22 years
you better take care of me because I've
been telling a lot of people in that 22
year period imagine how many times
people say where you going right I'm
going to the gym which gym 24-hour
Fitness every single time somebody asked
me where I'm going to work out and I
said 24-hour fitness I am doing free
marketing for you for 22 years you
better keep me if I get a credit card
that says been a member of a mix since
that's royalty you got to take care of
your loyalty a little bit above and
beyond everybody else number 11
not willing to take ownership
immediately by the way you've gone to an
argument with somebody and this is what
they say they say I can't believe you
said this and you made me feel like [ __ ]
and I think I just cannot stand you how
could you talk to me like that and that
person says this you ready that person
says this babe I am I'm so sorry man I
told him it stops my fault
dang they took ownership game over take
ownership you messed up there is nothing
else I took ownership it rather than
well if you officer Papa Papa Papa and
then Papa Papa friction take ownership
you know what I'm sorry can you I'm
sorry the fact that I made you feel that
way
I understand can you tell me a little
bit more about what caused you to feel
this way get into it and then you take
it from here
frustration to level 9 to level a to
level 7 to level 6 to level have it has
it ever happened to you it's happened to
me before I start like this and it Dana
calm me down and I came here and we're
talking like this Dana thank you so much
and then I'm thanking her on taking care
of me and I gave her love because you
just took ownership and brought them
over here very simple right number 12
it's assuming meaning you are assuming
that you know what the customer went
through so you'll hear a customer
service Oh sir I get it I understand I
get it I get it sir I get it no you
don't you're assuming you get me why
don't you ask me questions and let me
explain to you exactly how I feel next
one number 13 this is simple but it's
something it's so frustrating when a
customer goes through this is a bad
attitude I literally will walk through
my office and just look at people that
have bad attitudes and I have a
conversation with them they gonna feel
it over the phone you're gonna feel when
somebody has a bad attitude over the
phone is simple but it's fixable number
14 not building a relationship not
building a relationship so tell me about
your situation tell me what happened
please share it with me I understand I
am so sorry so what was the reasoning
for you going to Breckenridge what took
place here what happened over here tell
me about do you build in a relationship
you know you go to Zappos and the love
you give to Zappos is they talk to you
there's a relationship there's a
conversation that you being had with
them it's not just like let me get off
your phone over there ASAP because we
have to we have to meet her now there's
a little relationship that's why I was
so four billion plus and a lot of people
made money with it and they did what
they did because there was a
relationship based business number 15 a
lack of speed what is speed speed on
getting an answer to them speed on
getting back to them speed on a
resolution speed on talking to a
supervisor to have a supervisor call
them it's speed customer service
nowadays this may be unfair to the
businesses but today customers are
demanding
they want an answer faster you know they
want an answer on Twitter maybe 20 years
ago if there's an issue there was no
email 30 years ago maybe you gotta wait
and someone calls you back but not today
people want an answer on Twitter today
you have no idea how many businesses I
respond to and they don't even respond
back on Twitter it there is no customers
there is a Swedish so slow for them and
they think it's okay
but there is a reason why some of these
bigger companies competing at a bigger
scale and some of them are not speed
next talking too much instead of
listening conversation you're asking
them they ought to be speaking 80% of
time you need to be speaking 20% of time
next tone number 17 tone how are you
speaking to them what is your tonality
is it high is it fast or is it right in
a middle level easygoing calm relaxing
I may be intense right now with a lot of
energy I'm talking to you this is
definitely not the tone to be speaking
on these calls URI having her customer
service calls there you have them with
insa tone you can teach the tone to your
reps when you're speaking to them next
number 18 not empowering your staff what
do I mean about not empowering your
staff if I constantly undermine my staff
for not doing the right thing then it's
always like they're also like man I
don't want to take responsibility up
because if they talk to your
automatically gonna undermine me so
something like listen I understand what
you're saying with John John is actually
one of our better customer service reps
that we have here's been with us for six
and a half years but police tell me I'd
like to hear from you you know the Bobby
you just spoke to somebody that's very
good at what they do but I'm sorry about
your experience that yeah could you tell
me a little bit more about what happened
you're still not undermining everybody
that's there you're still empowering
them for them to be able to make some of
the bigger decisions hey what do I mean
by bigger decisions not a conversation
one of my reps today I said listen if
you speak to somebody and you feel it
make sense for you to go out and get by
a $50 gift and send it to them do you
need to come and just ask me can I get
this for 50 bucks
I empower you make the decision go do it
you don't need to ask me about a
something like that that's empowering I
felt here I can give this customer $50
discount rather than having to come to
my supervisor and wait seven minutes
until you're available empower them you
have the ability to give this much back
with this many customers you're
empowering them they solve the issue
faster and they move on and last but not
least this Alaska state companies make
is one
own audit calls and track it weekly what
do I mean by this so years ago I worked
at Bally Total Fitness and I worked at
three different clubs three gyms one was
Cobra City one was Hollywood and one was
Chatsworth the thing I love the most
about Culver City was a following there
was no private offices so everybody who
was selling gets what can we can hear we
could hear if somebody was
misrepresenting a gym membership and
saying this is month to month don't
worry about it we can cancel it in two
weeks no no you can't cancel in two
weeks you got 72 hours so we would hear
each other knobs and somebody would say
hey John what you just said it was great
but you can't say that again because
they can't cancel a week from now oh
okay no problem then all of a sudden I
would sit there and I would listen to a
guy named Molina Danny Molina to my left
I'm like wow what he said right there
was so beautiful in them when they
bought the membership I loved that and I
would write it down and then I would see
another guy named Joel race oh my gosh I
got was amazing then I will look at
Dexter McClendon then I went Francisco
Davis then I'm like wow Ruben Rimmer I'm
like oh my gosh these guys are amazing
and I was a learning from the guys that
were doing very good and and my track in
because my boss is caught that time was
listening to me
he was constantly hey David tried this
hey try that was good but try this try
this there was a constant weekly
auditing when I moved to Hollywood
everybody sold in private offices so
guess what nobody was learning from one
another what's my point to you I like
customer service to be in an open area
with desks right next to each other
wherever I can hear one another because
good can teach good and that can get
caught and filtered out quickly or
adjusted quickly before it turns to ugly
and all of a sudden you know got a
person here that said something on the
phone to a customer that the customers
right now you're getting a lawsuit or
complaint from there you got to deal
with that's the last thing you need so
in order to do that you got technology
nowadays you can track it you can listen
to all because you can have somebody's
job that the entire job is to listen and
monitor and do all those other things as
the company gets bigger but I'm assuming
you have less than 100 employees if you
have less than 100 employees and the
department's being ran by 20 people or
10 people that's easier for you to track
in an environment like this and once you
get to thousands of employees you'll
have the technology to help you do that
so now i told you earlier i'm gonna have
a free PDF for you i have it it's in the
description below click on a link below
go download the PDF
it out go through exactly what the eight
are in the nineteen common mistakes and
start highlighting which ones you do
well and which ones you don't print them
out for your employees your staff your
salespeople whoever it is you're working
with and go teach it to them guys we got
to get better in customer service we got
to get better at this and roleplay
here's we got to get better at this
here's we got to get better at that
because the reality part of it is this
is going to increase the value of your
business it's going to increase the
amount of referrals it's gonna increase
the amount of people sharing their
experiences with you and your value your
income goes out you start making more
money everybody starts making more money
the value goes higher so for some of you
guys I want to go even deeper into this
and you want to watch the video that I
did call customer service versus
customer experience you'll see the
thumbnail here to my right you can go
click also on the link below maybe on it
as well we're gonna put it on there
Mario or do we put the link below to
watch the video will it be on it okay
it'll be on it click on that to go watch
that episode as well and you'll kind of
get a little bit deeper dive on what I
mean by customer service versus customer
experience again more questions comments
thoughts comment on the bottom if you
haven't subscribed click on the sub
button take everybody bye-bye